this is the iHub in Nairobi it's a
creative workplace young IT
entrepreneurs programmers designers and
technology fans exchange ideas here hi
my name is Judy and I'm crazy bonito
gearbox which is the makerspace that we
are excited to set up a nervy and the
need for this is that there's been a
green how do your community in Kenya and
a gearbox they can run riot they work
with many computer modules such as
Raspberry Pi properly combined and
programmed these small computers can
control almost anything from a distance
but yeah I'm definitely excited to see
how things go and and begin I have be
realized like a lot so people ventures
depend on the internet and so we will be
helping their ventures rank better we'll
also be doing a lot of fan or mail
Solutions
Tanzania is still far from having
comprehensive internet coverage only in
Dar es Salaam is it or or less reliable
the women from apps and girls are
fighting their way into the digital
world as Carolyn Akira sama explains
together we my team because I always
call for those who know me
- tremendous
so we introduce them to pudding in teams
secondary school girls get to know new
programs and fledgling business women
learn how to program websites themselves
and all the competitions the hackathons
winners used to be maimed once you're a
woman or a gal and you're sharing
together you don't have this feeling his
most matter he's competing with me no
they are all the same and we are doing
one thing the small country of Rwanda
wants to become the Silicon Valley of
Africa its economic growth is now more
than 6% Kigali is the first city in
Africa to have high-speed wireless
internet ideal conditions for creative
spirits my name is Clarice and I run a
software company that focuses on
building mobile applications we've been
doing this for three years now
especially in rural areas that don't
have internet access much business has
to be done on the telephone
you're a buggy this company insures that
old priests Mart cell phones can connect
to the internet you know to focus on
building homegrown solutions that are
you know built around a community you
know get feedback improve their
solutions and just have a whole you know
um army we call it an army of developers
that and when people that really
understand what the problems are and
just helping us build this solution if
you want to be challenged and figure out
how to solve problems that you've never
even maybe thought would be there this
is the place that you definitely love to
come
so programmers of the world why wait
it's off to Africa
you